yeah uh thank you thanks for having me
here i apologize for the change in
time of the talk i got stuck in traffic
uh i thought one mile would not take
longer than
i don't know 30 minutes to get my car
but it took about an hour
so that was great uh anyway so i will be
talking about visual intelligence
uh mostly dealing with visual data which
is kind of
you know the biggest uh at least volume
wise data
out there so inter like you know i guess
most of the talks talk about big data
this is like
ginormous data uh just as an example
uh i think roger earlier was talking
about the internet archive which has
about 17
petabytes of data facebook
in 2012 actually receives ris was
receiving seven petabytes of
images every single month so within
three months it was making up
you know much more than the internet
archive and
who knows how much they're getting right
now it's always been growing
so i'll be talking about you know how to
deal with some of that data
as well as how to get some something
intelligent
uh back from it so looking forward so
you know imagine you're on a vacation uh
you're with your
son you're you're taking a walk suddenly
he turns to you
and he's like daddy daddy i want
mcdonald's
and you know he's thinking of his happy
meal he really wants that you know
and you're like sure i can have a burger
too it's going to make me pretty happy
so what's the first thing you do you
pull out your cell phone
and it's oh crap it's out of battery
you know this happens more often than
not and you're like it's fine
we gotta find mcdonald's you see his
cute face and
you gotta walk your way there so you
walk you end up at this
intersection which way do you think
might be the right one to go
any okay i i assume you guys know this
uh and then again you're walking and you
hit this intersection
so which way do you think you should go
you're with your son you want to be safe
uh you know probably the left one so
that's nice you bumble around the city a
little more and finally you end up at
mcdonald's everything's happy
everything's great
so basically the idea i'm proposing here
is that an image is much more than just
a simple composition of its visual
elements so as an example
a lot of prior work in computer vision
has focused on
given an image like this let's try and
label what's inside the image
so just something extremely obvious like
you know there's a ferris wheel there's
a bunch of people there
uh what are some of the activities
people are performing but
there's a lot more that we can get from
an image and
the question that i ask in this talk is
what you know
how how much farther can we go so just
as an example
of different scales of you know how far
we can go from
just the obvious image let's take a look
at this image here
so some of the most obvious things
people in computer vision have been
doing for some time is
let's just label all the objects say you
know we have buildings here
cars here and so on let's say we want to
be a slightly more precise
all right we've labeled exactly which
pixels belong to person which pixels
belong to car
but now let's try and you know try and
get something a little more
uh than just what is inside the image
let's say we have this car here
uh we blow it up so there's some part of
the car that's occluded
so maybe we can infer you know based on
all the cars we've seen in the world
that's kind of what it would look like
and if i turn that car around you know
maybe
it looks something like that uh
hopefully more real but
you get the idea so similarly you can do
this
uh for other objects and so this is you
know
still right very close to the image uh
now let's see let's say what like you
know if i ask you to imagine what's the
scene outside this particular image
people would have a pretty good guess
and i can imagine it would look
something like that
so that's still staying really close to
the image
now let's take a step further let's
assume that image
is taken from you know that part on the
street somewhere say in paris
now what would the image
of the street over there look like so
this is what you guys were guessing when
you were trying to find mcdonald's right
you're you're not seeing a mcdonald's in
the image but you're trying to infer
where it might be based on
the visual elements that are present in
the scene so that's exactly what this
problem is
and now let's take a step even further
so you know you have this image
it's anywhere on the interwebs you know
it might be taken in
who knows where like libya you're seeing
it in the u.s
and now we want to try and infer what is
the
impact this image has on you when you're
looking at it
so you know do you remember the image do
you
press like on the image and so on so
that's kind of
a big overview of what i'll be covering
in the talk firstly we'll you know
formalize this problem of trying to find
mcdonald's
uh secondly we'll look at can we predict
how popular an image is going to be even
before it's uploaded
the next thing is can we predict whether
people are going to remember a
particular image or not
and lastly can we act you know given all
these non-visual elements
can we actually modify the image to
affect these non-visual properties so
can i make
an image you know can i make an image
stick in your mind more than
uh just what it normally would have so
let's begin by
finding mcdonald's so given a map like
this
so right now i'll formalize how we you
know did the problem so
given a map like this like street view
we have a bunch of locations of
mcdonald's
so let's take a look at a particular
location uh
we get you know we we sample
images from random places on street view
we see
look those are the ones that are close
to mcdonald's that's what they look like
and our task is very simple we ask
people which of the two do you think is
closer to mcdonald's
so which one any guesses here
i guess there's actually a mcdonald's in
the top image so i hope everyone's going
to say that
but essentially we want to see whether
this task is feasible at all to begin
with because it's such a weird you know
you wouldn't imagine that people would
be able to do this uh you know
statistically significantly
so and as well as we want to see if
machines can do this right
so we put man versus machine so
sim you know we use our favorite
crowdsourcing interface
amazon mechanical turk where you can
just query a bunch of people about
simple tasks or complex tasks and pay
them accordingly
so we uh ask them
you know we show them two images and we
just ask them which one do you think is
closer to mcdonald's
so if they were acting at chance we
would get an
accuracy of about 50 percent
and similarly we can ask the machine we
give it an image
we convert it into some sort of
representation that the computer
understands
we apply our favorite machine learning
algorithm and
use that to predict uh what is the
distance to mcdonald's
so what happens when we tried this so
fortunately
it did not you know people were doing
well above chance at about 60 percent
so about 60 of pairs of images they were
able to correctly tell that oh look this
one is probably closer to mcdonald's
than the other one
which was kind of nice so we're like
good machines do the same thing
and fortunately or you know surprisingly
actually
machines performed even better than
humans
at doing this task and then we tried it
out in a bunch of other cities so
this was again using you know really big
data it was
about i think 20 million images that we
sampled from google street view
and we applied it to like a bunch of
them
here so similarly we see that in most of
the cities
machines are actually able to outperform
humans in
understanding what's going on in this
large
data set to you know figure out which
images are closer or farther from
mcdonald's
so this was just a simple task where you
do a binary decision
but now can we actually find our way to
mcdonald's we really want that happy
meal so
imagine i drop you at some random
location in manhattan
and i'm like go try and find mcdonald's
based on
uh you know the visual cues you get from
the environment don't talk to people
or use your phone so can you do this
navigation task
uh where you just you know step on these
grids that's how we set it up for the
machine
uh to find your way to mcdonald's
and surprisingly people are actually
able to do pretty well
you know compared to just doing like a
random walk of the environment people
can get there
many many times faster and there's
another part of the result
which shows that the random walk
actually fails you know most of the time
while people are fairly good at
navigating to
you know within like 50 meters off a
mcdonald's uh
as well as computers which do a
reasonable job
so we have a we'll soon have a demo
online at you know mcdonalds.co.mit.edu
so you guys can
try it out and see if you can find your
way to mcdonald's
so this was the first step you know just
looking right outside the image
or looking at the environment uh around
the image
so the next one is let's try and predict
how many people are going to like a
particular image
so what exactly is image popularity so
different networks have different
notions of this uh for example on
instagram it might be the number of
people that like a particular image
on facebook it might similarly be be the
number of people that like it
or the number of comments the image gets
so
uh on you know something like twitter it
might again be the number of retweets
favorites and so on
but for this study we used a flicker
which actually reports the number of
views
on a particular image which to me is
like a more pure metric
because there are many times you might
open an image
but not necessarily click like on it as
an example if your friend uploads an
image like that you might be
you know you might take a look at it but
you might not want to press like
out of you know feeling
yeah for obvious reasons or for example
there's a funeral scene it might be you
know you might open it take a look but
pressing like may be
not very uh nice essentially so
whereas views actually gives you all of
this so as long as i've clicked on the
image
it registers a view so it actually tells
you like it gives you a more pure metric
of what people
actually look at so why exactly
does it matter why do we want to predict
uh which images are going to be popular
so firstly you know we want to do
content distribution
across our network so if we can predict
that this image is likely to get
extremely high traffic
we can prepare for that secondly i think
this is one of the biggest problems
uh you know plaguing teens uh
of this generation is the problem of
selfie selection
uh people take so many selfies and they
don't know which one to upload
imagine if i could tell you look this
selfie is probably going to get you more
likes than this other one
won't it just save them a bunch of time
instead of spending hours
you know doing this they could be
studying or so
another obvious uh application of this
is also in advertising
um we would you know like you want to
select images that are likely to get
popular
you want virality you want to figure
this out before you put your
ad campaign online so just as an example
this is one of
an advert for funeral services
so there's actually a bunch of other uh
applications of this like you know video
summarization
you want to understand user behavior and
so on
so how did we go about doing this
first we generate a data set of 2.3 like
million flickr images where we just
download
a whole bunch of random flickr images we
get the views on these images
and we use our again our same pipeline
that we had before
to try and predict how many views the
image is going to get
so just using the content and ignoring a
lot of the social features which tend to
have
a big impact uh on these metrics such as
you know how many friends you have
like what groups you're part of and so
on
we just used the content of the image
which is something that people had not
looked at before so we want to try and
figure out you know using different
types of
image features which ones
are going to have a bigger impact so for
example these are just some popular
vision features like texture gradient
and so on and deep learning features
which have recently become quite popular
for those of you who may have heard of
it
as well as some high level features such
as the type of objects in the image
so surprisingly we can actually do
pretty well
uh predicting you know at a rank
correlation of 0.4
uh which images are going to be more
popular but i think the more interesting
part is looking at what causes the
popularity
so for example we can start looking at
which colors
tend to increase the popularity of
images so we tend to find like you know
more bright colors more
greens sorry more reds and so tend to
have a bigger impact as compared to
uh like the more greens and blues which
might suggest that you know indoor
images tend to be slightly more
like tend to have a higher popularity uh
as compared to outdoor seat type images
so this kind of the stuff people like
looking at
uh the next thing is let's try and
predict what like let's try and figure
out what objects tend to cause
you know more or less popular images so
we use a similar
uh pipeline as before where we now
instead of having you know these complex
image features we have
uh the object likelihood which just says
these are the objects present in the
image
now use this to predict uh what's going
like you know which ones are going to be
popular
and why we have to do this is because
it's
you know my advisor was like you can
either finish your phd
or we can use that money to label the
2.3 million images we have so
you know which one i chose and instead
we applied the best like computer vision
algorithm we know
uh to try and predict the objects
instead of getting them labeled
uh by hand so these are some of the
results from that
um we find that you know some of the
rare objects such as i guess
giant like having giant pandas or
ladybugs uh
you know if you can find these they tend
to have a medium positive impact
uh on popularity but the objects that
have the most positive impact
uh are these ones so
you know it's obvious why guys like them
and i guess girls like checking out
other girls
so uh it's like universally acceptable
like
or universally popular uh and then the
objects that have negative impact
uh tend to be like spatulas so you know
stop having spatulas in your images
or plungers or the photos that everyone
loves taking
probably possibly in this room is with
your laptop stop doing that
it does not help the popularity of your
images so
this thing was actually uh pretty fun so
we decided to make a demo where people
could upload
uh their images online to check this
thing so
within like i think so you know it was
on a bunch of like media outlets and
such
uh within i think three days we had
about 300 000 images
uploaded uh which was awesome and you
know we had a lot of content
but it was amazing to see how passionate
people were
about this uh this is one of my favorite
emails from the time
she had uploaded some images and she was
like these girls you know they deserve a
better score and
she was extremely like into uh
the calculator and it was just nice to
see uh
you know compared to most of the other
research that goes on
how much people care about this stuff
uh so the next step is so one you know
first we were predicting popularity now
we want so that was predicting what
people like but now we want to try and
predict what people remember
from images so what exactly is
memorability so
let me just define vulnerability as the
likelihood of remembering a particular
image
this is kind of boring so why don't you
guy so i think the best way for you guys
to learn about this is to participate
in the experiment itself so we will play
a visual memory game
uh you guys are just going to clap your
hands anytime you see an image that you
have seen before
so images will flash one image per
second and
if you've seen them like if you see the
image in this sequence before just clap
your hands alright
everybody got it let me see those hands
okay
they're not supposed to clap on it
okay this usually works better uh but
yeah
all right so you guys were clapping so
this experiment was conducted on amazon
mechanical turk
uh where people were seeing these
repeats and pressing a key whenever they
saw one
and memorability can now be defined
as the probability of correctly
detecting this repeat so the
in this case i'd put the repeats you
know maybe within like five images after
uh but on mturk these repeats were about
100 images after so there are many times
that
images were forgotten but a large
proportion of the times the images were
remembered
so the really interesting aspect of this
uh
is if i now you know suppose i have 100
people participate in my experiment
and i divide them into two groups
of like 50 people each and plot the
memorability or you know this
probability of correctly detecting a
repeat
for each of these two groups
independently i get a graph something
like that
so you just sort it by the memorability
and the very interesting thing is
they actually correspond to each other
so despite you know having completely
random workers on mturk who might be
i don't know like housewives in the u.s
like
rickshaw drivers in india and you know
people who are just participating from
around the world
despite having varied completely varied
backgrounds
their the extent to which they remember
different images is actually the same
so you know you and i the probability
with which we'll remember
a given image is actually a property of
the image and not of the individual
so which is really cool and as we added
more and more people
into the experiment you know that's the
number of scores per image means
each image was viewed by like 80 or so
people
uh the rank correlation between the two
groups kept increasing
and there was a point where we kind of
ran out of money so
and you know you can split these two
groups in any way you want and
you get a really high rank correlation
every single time
which suggests that memorability is an
intrinsic
and measurable property of an image and
just another interesting aspect is
look at the range of differences so
there's a lot of images that you know
less than like 40 of people remember
while there are some images that more
than 90
remember so there's just some images
that you know tend to stick in our minds
while others
are completely forgotten and
this means that we can actually start
you know playing with
the content of the image to affect how
much we will remember it
and starting to make a lot of low
memorability images
memorable so but before we can do that
we need to you know be modifying
memorability in a predictable way
so first we need to be able to predict
memorability
so first we just tried some simple
statistics right like
maybe having a really bright image makes
it extremely memorable or just having a
lot of red in the image makes it
memorable
but what we found is that there was not
very much correlation with any of these
simple
statistics uh and what people remember
so the next thing we tried was you know
the standard computer vision features
and we're like oh this is pretty good
uh we're getting you know somewhere we
can actually predict with
a rank correlation of 0.5 while humans
only have a consistency of 0.75 so we're
you know two-thirds of the way there
so that's pretty good now we're like
you know in computer vision and many
other uh
like fields like machine learning what
we have is ground truth
is what people say so we thought
why don't we ask people what do they
think they will remember so we have this
way you know we have our study we have
uh some approach of measuring what they
actually remembered
and then the other question we can ask
is what do you think you will remember
and we had to create a special place up
top for how people
performed they actually behaved as good
as random number generators so
people have no idea what kind of images
they're going to remember they just
like it's yeah we tried the question in
many different ways and this is the best
uh kind of we could do most people just
people are just guessing which is
actually kind of great
because uh that means that
it has a lot of room for algorithms
which can predict memorability
to you know make a difference here
because if i ask you to
be if i give you an image and be like
all right use photoshop or do whatever
you want
and try and make this image more
memorable you'd have no idea how to do
it because
you don't even know what the notion of
memorability is
and you don't even know how memorable
this image is versus what happens after
you make changes
while the algorithms can actually do a
reasonable job at predicting this
so there's a like it's a you know very
diff like it's a machine learning task
turned on its head
uh where humans are terrible at it
so that brings us to modifying
memorability
so imagine if something like this was
possible imagine if i could change
the extent to which you remember images
how could this be
useful so firstly obviously in
advertising right like imagine if i just
had to show you an image once you
remember it sticks in your mind
you know i've cluttered your mind with
garbage but
you just can't forget this image the
other one is logos right
people keep advertising and putting
logos everywhere just in hopes that
next time you see this logo you have
some brand familiarity
now imagine if i can change your logo to
just make it
extremely memorable so you show it once
people remember it
so these are some like i guess people
would call it like adverse uh
applications but think about you know
good ones now if in education uh where
we have a lot of
content that we need to memorize if we
just changed
visually how it's presented uh we could
make the task of
remembering all this so much easier
you know imagine if you had a harder
time like forgetting it than remembering
it
uh another obvious one mobile
applications we just want to
you know change all our images to be
more memorable imagine a new memorable
filter on instagram
uh our social networking where we're
posting uh
all the things we do and we want our
friends to remember it
as well as face memorability right like
you know
imagine like a job application where out
of whatever some number of resumes
your face is the one that's remembered
so
in this current uh work i looked at
phase modifying face memorability
specifically
so given a face like this uh can we
actually
you know move it along this memorability
axis while still trying to preserve the
identity of this guy we don't want to
lose
him but we want to change the image
subtly
to make it more or less memorable so
these are just some examples
uh produced so you can see you know some
of the lighting has changed uh
there's there's some minor effects that
happen you know some like slightly the
eyes
the corners have changed but it actually
has a pretty big
impact on how much we remember the
different images so over here you know
putting them side by side you guys can
see the differences
but if i you know showed you one then
showed you the other you'd be like
that's the same image i just saw
uh which seems to suggest that you know
the identity is preserved and so on so
how do we go about doing this
uh let's just we have some space of a
face let's say
x where the face is parameterized by
this x
and we can move it in this space so just
imagine you know
you have those points you can just hold
and drag
right like you can drag it in different
dimensions and such so you can drag like
you drag it in one way that's like you
know the guy's face becomes fatter
another way it becomes thinner he looks
younger and so on so
you now have the space where you can
change you can start modifying a face
so we now define a cost function to
you know how do we want to change this
face
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to preserve identity so
if we change identity the cost function
goes up
secondly we want to preserve some
attributes so you know usu
hopefully by the end of the modification
the dude doesn't start looking like a
girl or some you know
or vice versa uh and the last so you
know these two will keep the face
exactly the same so now we need a
competing term which will
cause it to have a predictable effect on
memorability
which is again you know which is the the
last term so this term is going to say
you know the current memorability is x
we want it to be x plus 0.5
for example and now try and modify the
face
under these constraints so you know i
won't go more into like the math and
such
but uh here are just some example
results
so faces you know i think one of like
these are just three results but one of
the things that you can see that's
happening for
more memorable faces is they tend to get
like slightly thinner
the ship the shape of the lips and such
changes a little bit
uh as well as just the expression of the
person
has also changed and a lot of these
things are extremely hard to notice like
if i gave you
i don't know i'll give you 10 000 images
with memorability scores now go and
figure out
uh you know what exactly causes it it's
extremely hard to determine this by
looking
just staring at that data whereas for
the machine it's
much easier to parse through all that
data and identify what are some of these
characteristics affecting
memorability and it's actually able to
do it in a fairly predictable way so
out of all the modifications we made 75
percent of them
were completely predictable so the graph
you know the blue one is showing the
ones where we took a face
and increased its memorability and the
red one is where we took the same face
and decreased its memorability
and it's you know it's happening uh
pretty consistently
so i guess the end goal is you know
something like this where we have a
iphone app where people are just able to
you know
twiddle their memorability around uh as
well as
change so there's some other attributes
that we've been working on as well like
you want to try looking more confident
you want to look more intelligent you
want to look
you know all these soft attributes apart
from the ones that are
i don't know if you've seen on the app
store there's a lot of apps for looking
just
more attractive and that's all you know
putting makeup and such but
imagine a whole bunch of other
applications where you want to put this
photo on your cv you don't want to just
necessarily look more attractive but you
want to be maybe more confident
more intelligent and so on and you can
start
hopefully doing this someday so yeah a
lot of this work was covered again by
you know popular media outlets and such
uh which was great
we got a lot of feedback and so on
so i guess just to reiterate what i had
covered first we started
you know our goal was to look beyond the
visible scene and we started by looking
what is next to the image finding
mcdonald's and then predicting
how people would react to a particular
image which is whether they're going to
like it in terms of popularity
or whether they will remember it and
lastly how can we modify some of these
non-visual properties by changing the
visual elements of the image
which was the modifying vulnerability so
i just want to thank my co-authors and
funding sources and such
and obviously thanks to all you guys for
being here